at the start of Game of Thrones Tyrion
Lannister is a rich dwarf who loves
drinking and sex he's also smart and
sensitive
he feels unloved and mistreated so he
uses his sarcastic drunk persona to
protect himself from emotional pain
Tyrians relationship with his family is
complicated he loves his brother Jamie
but his father Tywin and sister Cersei
treat him as an embarrassment to their
proud family so from the start tyrians
loyalty to the Lannisters is in question
Jaime asks whose side his on Tyrion
visits the wall the pisses off the edge
of the world and makes friends with Jon
Snow Tyrion gives bran a special saddle
so he can ride after his crippled as a
dwarf Tyrion has sympathy for cripples
bastards and broken things Catelyn Stark
arrests Tyrion on false charges and
brings him to Lysa who locks him in a
sky cell Tyrion goes free after a trial
by combat thanks to the mercenary bran
they're both almost killed by Hill
tribesmen but Tyrion convinces them to
join him Tyrion is really good at
talking his way out of danger and
turning enemies into allies Tyrians
father Tywin has quote always been a
[ __ ]
treating Tyrion as a constant
disappointment he gives Tyrion a chance
to prove himself sending Tyrion to the
capital to rule as hand of the king
but Tywin forbids Tyrion from bringing
his mistress the prostitute Shae Tywin
and Tyrion have a history with women
Tyrion had once married a common girl
called Tasha and Tywin thought she was
unworthy so he had her gang-raped Tyrion
and Tywin's relationship is poisoned
with misogyny shame and resentment
so in defiance of his father Tyrion
brings Shae to King's Landing in season
1 Tyrians smart funny persona masks deep
insecurities and pain in season 2 Tyrion
rules as hand of creating conflict with
Cersei who wants the power to herself
he also butts heads with Joffrey the
psycho little [ __ ] King Tyrion forms
an uneasy alliance with Varys who sees
potential in Tyrion and Tyrion secretly
continues his relationship with
J Tyrion and Sosa's rivalry spirals into
violence Circe's furious when Tyrion
sends her daughter to dawn so Cersei
tries to hurt him by beating Rose who
she thinks is Tyrians lover and Tyrion
threatens Cersei promising to turn her
joy into ashes in her mouth King's
Landing is attacked by Stannis and
Tyrion defends the city he destroys
Stannis's fleet with wildfire and
personally leads an attack his face is
cut by a Kingsguard and he's saved by
his faithful Squire Podrick Shae
declares her love to Tyrion and asks him
to start a new life with her but Tyrion
feels he belongs in the politics of
King's Landing so in season two Tyrion
finds new purpose in playing the game of
Thrones but then Tywin returns and takes
all the credit for saving the city from
Stannis and Tywin replaces Tyrion as
hand of the king so in season three
Tyrion confronts Tywin and demands
recognition for helping the family
Tyrion asks his father for love and
approval but Tywin gives him cruelty and
contempt he describes his hatred and
disgust for Tyrion for his drinking and
whoring and for being a dwarf he blames
Tyrion for his mother's death in
childbirth says Tyrion will never
inherit the family castle and that he'll
kill Tyrians next [ __ ]
Tyrion keeps on trying to prove himself
working as master of coin but Tywin
still refuses to acknowledge him Tyrion
makes a point of rewarding Podrick with
a trip to the brothel Tyrion gives POD
the love and approval that Tyrion wishes
he got from Tywin Tyrion takes solace
with Shae and also confides in bran
Tywin makes Tyrion marry Sansa Stark
which puts Tyrion in an awkward position
he wants to keep Shae happy but he also
wants to do right by Sansa Tywin tells
Tyrion to get Sansa pregnant so the
Lannisters can claim the north
Tyrion refuses to force himself on Sansa
and all the old resentments over Taisha
return Tyrion gets drunk and threatens
King Joffrey and Tywin reminds Tyrion
how much he hates him so by the end of
season 3
Tyrion stuck in a deeply uncomfortable
his mistresses pissed his father hates
him the King hates him and the realm is
racked with war how long can it go on
Tyrion asks in season four tyrion tries
to help his wife Sansa as she graves for
her murdered family when Jaime comes
home without a hand it kind of brings
the brothers closer now that they're
both crippled service aught says he
finds out about Shae so Tyrion tries to
break up with her to send her away to
safety
Shae refuses to leave him so Tyrion gets
hurtful saying that she's a [ __ ] that
she's not good enough echoing Tywin's
hate Tyrion hurts the one he loves in
trying to protect her Joffrey's wedding
Joffrey publicly humiliates Tyrion and
when Joffrey's poisoned
so she accuses Tyrion of the murder the
trial goes badly and gets worse when
Shae testifies against Tyrion probably
under duress by Cersei tyrion feels
deeply betrayed by the woman he loved by
his father and by the whole city who
turned against Tyrion after he'd saved
them all from Stannis a lifetime of pain
and hate comes pouring out he says I
wish I was the monster you think I am
Tyrion demands trial by combat but his
champion Prince Oberyn is killed so
Tyrion is sentenced to death by his own
father for a crime he didn't commit in
the finale Jaime and Vera's break Tyrion
out of jail and Tyrion finds out that
Shae has become Tywin's lover this shows
the total hypocrisy of tywin's hatred
for [ __ ]
and it shows the depth of Shay's
betrayal she calls Tywin my lion when
that was her pet name for Tyrion Shaye
takes a knife and Tyrion strangles her
then he apologizes to her corpse because
after all she didn't ask for any of this
when Tyrion took her in season one
finally Tyrion confronts his father who
still refuses to respect Tyrians
feelings Tywin says you're no son of
mine and Tyrion replies I have always
been your son because Tyrion and Tywin
are alike they have the same
insecurities around power and pride
at women and love and in the end they
have the same cold brutality Tyrion
kills his father and leaves the country
with Varys in season 4
Tyrion struggle for love and acceptance
ends with betrayal and murder in season
5 Tyrion is depressed and hopeless
filled with guilt and self-loathing for
killing Tywin and Shae Varys wants him
to help Daenerys and Tyrion goes along
with it just because he's got nothing
better to do while he drinks himself to
death in volantis Tyrion is captured by
Jorah who also wants to take him to
Daenerys in Valyria Tyrion sees Daenerys
dragon drogon Tyrion has always been
fascinated by dragons and seeing one for
real brings a sense of hope and
wonderment back to his life
Tyrion needs something to live for and
Jorah says the Daenerys is worth
believing in
Jorah and Tyrion are attacked by stone
men then they're captured by slavers
Tyrion talks about his [ __ ] and he ends
up meeting Queen Daenerys he convinces
Daenerys to take him on as a political
adviser he is useful to her because he
knows the politics of Westeros and he
knows Queen Cersei and Tyrion and
Daenerys have a lot in common both of
their fathers were powerful and cruel
politicians both of their mothers died
in childbirth both of them like
political power but also have compassion
for the wake so Daenerys and Tyrion get
along they try to make peace in Moraine
by working with his door and opening the
fighting pits and that all turns to [ __ ]
but Tyrion gets to see Daenerys taking
flight on a dragon showing him that
there is still magic and hope in the
world in season five
Tyrion finds someone to believe in in
season six Daenerys is gone and Tyrion
is left to bring peace to a divided and
dangerous marine it's a huge political
challenge and a chance to prove himself
to his new queen Tyrion starts by
unchaining Dany's dragons and he gets
the red priests to support Daenerys but
the main threat is the sons of the harpy
and Tyrion learns they're funded by the
nearby slave Cities so Tyrion makes a
peace deal with the slavers the grey
worm amis and I warn him
that it won't work for a while there's
pace in moraine Faris leaves and Tyrion
says that he'll miss him
Tyrion tries to make friends with grey
worm and Masson die Tyrians a long way
from home
and he's lonely just when marine seems
safe the slavers attack Tyrians peace
deal fails and everything goes to [ __ ]
just as Daenerys returns so danny is not
impressed but she still listens to
Tyrians advice he convinces her not to
go full fire and blood on the slavers
and instead to just kill some and warn
the rest not to attack again he oversees
Danny's alliance with the Greyjoy's and
he tells it a breakup with Daario so
she's open to marriage
Daenerys sees the value in Tyrians
advice and he's impressed by her
compromises and self-sacrifice they
respect each other and Tyrion starts to
fall in love with her he declares his
loyalty to Daenerys and she names him
hand of the Queen from Daenerys Tyrion
finally gets the respect and approval
that he never got from his father in
season 7 Tyrion comes home to Westeros
with Daenerys invading army
Tyrion helps plan the war against his
own siblings Cersei and Jaime and Tyrion
says not to attack King's Landing with
dragons because that would kill
thousands of people including his family
Tyrion encourages Dany to team up with
Jon and his friendship with Jon helps
build this powerful alliance but Tyrians
war plans fail his strategy loses
Daenerys that Dornish Greyjoy sand
Tyrells
Daenerys questions Terry Ann's loyalty
maybe Tyrion doesn't want her to destroy
the Lannisters because they're his
family when Daenerys burns a Lannister
army Tyrion watches in horror as his
brother Jaime is almost killed he walked
through the ashes of his family's army
and randyll Tarly condemns Tyrion for
betraying his family and his homeland
Tyrion is disturbed when Danny burns the
tallies Tyrion still believes that
Daenerys could be a great Queen
but his loyalty is torn between her and
his family Tyrion meets with Jaime and
tries to explain his feelings about
their father
Tyrion arranges the peace
between Danny and Susy and when it
breaks down Tirion faces his sister so
she hates him for killing Tywin but
Tyrion wants her to know that he never
meant to hurt their family he feels
terrible about the deaths of her kids
and of Tywin Tyrion tries desperately to
make peace and Cersei tricks him she
uses her pregnancy to convince Tyrion
that she'll help Daenerys fight the dead
when so she's actually planning to
betray them on the way north Tyrion is
disturbed when Danny and Jon have sex
partly because Tyrion kind of loves Dany
but also because this complicates the
political situation so in season seven
Tyrians loyalties are torn he wants
Daenerys to make the world better but he
also wants to protect his family
Jaime and Cersei and her unborn child so
what will happen with Tyrion in the
final season it looks like Jaime will
join Daenerys against the dead and Jaime
could tell Tyrion that says he's
planning to betray everyone which might
make it easier for Tyrion to side
against Cersei but still Tyrion has
sympathy for broken things and Cersei is
the broken instead of all maybe Tyrion
will still want to protect his sister
and her unborn child
there are theories that Cersei and
Tyrion made some secret deal like to
make Circe's child heir to the throne or
something Tyrion might get back with
bran and pod the old squad back together
again
he'll probably reunite with his ex-wife
Sansa Sansa appreciates that Tyrion was
good to her and Tyrion knows that Sansa
smart maybe they could form a political
alliance and Tyrion could advise her
Tyrion might get closer with Dany's
dragons there are theories that Tyrion
is a secret Targaryen though I've
already got one of those
still it'd be cool if Tyrion rode a
dragon and he does have experience
designing special saddles if Tyrion
survives to the end maybe he'll help
Daenerys break the wheel and introduce
democracy to Westeros like he suggested
last season or maybe he'll rule Casterly
Rock to spite Tywin who said he never
would maybe he'll start that winery he
mentioned in season six or maybe he'll
die at the age of 80 with a belly full
of wine and a girl on his [ __ ] as in
season 1 vet tearian story is defined by
tragedy there are hints in the books
that Tyrion might lose his tongue or
maybe he'll lose his life
Tyrion might never get the love and
acceptance that he craves but most of
all let's just hope we get the punchline
to that joke about the jackass and the
honeycomb thanks for watching please
subscribe and press the bell we're
holding a live stream right off to H
episode of Thrones Season 8 we've also
got merged now so you can get all chief
decks shirts and pins at the link below
thank you to the patrons including
shenanigans MC Stephanie Canon Jordan
Schafer Joel Trombley Maggie Greenberg
mystery mich list of null and earth
Cheers
you